Good evening everyone. It's so wonderful
to have friends from all over the city
all over the world joining us this
evening. It's a rare privilege to work
with an institution like MoMA PS1, and of
course The Museum of Modern Art, on a
project like this that happens every
year, and in the 18th year in the 18th
incarnation, it's been a true joy to work
with Jenny Sabin very closely as the
projects and the installation that you
see here has evolved, and it's one of the
first and only instances I can imagine
where a rendering—which those of us in
the architecture community have become
accustomed to for better or worse—but
the work itself is so much better than
the rendering, and not only from the idea
of detail and the immersive quality, but
the fact that one can still get lost in
an architecture of today. Lumen, of course, is here all summer and I highly
recommend all of you come to Warm Up and enjoy it in its full glory, day and night.
Thank you.
Wow. Thank you, Sean. Thank you, Anita.
Thank you, Klaus. Thanks to all of you for
coming out this evening. It's really
amazing to be at this point within the
YAP program. I've learned so much—it's
been thrilling, it's been intense, and
super exciting. So Lumen really is an
experiment. It's about taking risks
through collaboration across disciplines
and, more specifically, held in tension as
you can see within the PS1 courtyard
matrix of walls, Lumen applies insights
and theories from both biology, material
science, yes and mathematics—yes, I do like math—and engineering.
I thank so much to all of you for coming
out, and I hope you join us until about
9:15. Soon the photoluminescent
threads will start to glow and emit
light... And I'm really excited to be here.
Thank you.